voters in mongolia going to the polls to
choose their new president
this is the first vote to take place
after constitutional amendments stripped
the presidency of some of its powers
restricting office holders to a single
six-year term
and the nation's third election to take
place in the shadow of the covet-19
pandemic
at a polling station in the capital
voters had their temperatures scanned
and observed social distancing
i really hope that the new president i
chose today will put our economy back on
its feet
due to the coronavirus pandemic the
mongolian economy is really struggling
it almost fell on its knees
unemployment is an urgent matter that
needs an immediate solution
so in order to do that foreign
investment is very important
so i really hope the new president i
chose today will improve mongolia's
reputation abroad and bring in more
foreign investment
the ruling mongolians people party is
looking to consolidate power
with former prime minister uchna
kurelsuch widely considered the
front-runner
in a campaign speech he emphasized the
importance of self-sufficiency for
mongolia
each year we spend around 1.5 billion
american dollars on buying petrol from
outside our country
if this money stays in mongolia the u.s
dollar exchange rate will drop
tremendously
the toogrich currency value will
strengthen we will not need to worry
about petrol prices
another concern is political instability
which continues to be a problem for a
young democracy
that after decades of communist rule
passed its first constitution in 1992
amnesty international has voiced concern
about ongoing suppression of dissent
saying the election will take place amid
a worrying human rights situation
a sentiment echoed by the opposition
democratic party's presidential
candidate
at a campaign rally in the run-up to the
vote
today's mongolia in spite of being a
democratic country is now seeing a new
oppression taking place
political abuse has become too much that
is why the democratic party being the
main
opposition force nationwide has decided
to bring forth the idea of mongolia
without oppression
mongolia with democracy some political
activists believe the elections aren't
even legal
mongolia has been a democracy for 31
years but nothing goes as it should
fairly nothing in a real democratic way
according to laws
the laws are just not implemented
mongolia
which often finds itself in a political
and economic tug of war between china
and russia
has a population of around 3.3 million
people
with inequality being a major concern
among voters and the country battling a
resurgence of coronavirus infections
a key question will be just how much a
new president will be able to turn
things around
mohammed